this video is sponsored by current
manage your money your way
[Music]
all right look listen i don't need to
tell you this you know i love dragon
ball and contained in this video are the
arcs that cemented dragon ball as one of
my favorite stories of all time it's
such a magical and terrific world full
of bizarre funny heartfelt and
inspirationally powerful stories not to
mention characters and so today i'm
taking an in-depth look at two
tournaments in this story the first
being fortune teller baba's champion
knockout contest and finally the 22nd
tenkaichi budokai the first world
tournament since the last epic encounter
between jackie chan and goku and the
first time were introduced to the
intimidating and arrogant tenshinhan
hold on to your socks everyone because
we're diving in i'm toying up mark and
this is my review of akira toriyama's
underrated and undefeated dragon ball
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fortune teller baba the red ribbon army
arc while very action and suspense
focused i thought lacked emotional
resonance in the first and second arcs i
covered in this review series i
mentioned how my favorite aspects of
both were what they brought to the table
in an emotional capacity goku sharing
his memories of his grandpa in pilaf's
castle informing us of his tragic
circumstances and in the 21st tenkaichi
budokai roshi's moving of heaven and
earth in an effort to try and instill
the right teachings in his pupils these
are all brilliantly subversive ideas
that in addition to the comedy in action
helped to elevate all of the material
being told far beyond what would have
otherwise been achieved without it
dragon ball is very much a story of
action and comedy but without certain
measured and appropriate levels of drama
almost all of the action loses its sense
of weight tao paipai's encounter with
goku was powerful because it was
entirely driven by drama upa's father
had been murdered and so goku had to try
to improve enough such that the next
time he fought tau he would be able to
prevent him from doing more damage to
more people and driven by that emotional
resonance goku rematches tau to great
success however as you may have noticed
last week i decided to quickly scan over
goku's attack on the red ribbon army
base and i did so because that section
was simply just action and comedy there
was virtually no drama involved which i
think is a crying shame goku just
defeats the red ribbon army plowing
through their ranks with hardly any
resistance and i decided to end it there
because it was the end of the titular
red ribbon army for which the ark is
known for well for now but what if i
told you that wasn't the actual ending
of the arc one of the best aspects to
the format dragon ball employs is that
of using comedy and action as a vehicle
for telling stories that have an
emotional core and while the main action
and comedic climaxes have reached their
conclusions through the dismantling of
the red ribbon army themselves there
still exists the emotional climax to
this arc while many might consider this
part separate from the prior red ribbon
army material this arc still very much
is intrinsically connected to the prior
having begun with a less compelling
desire from goku to reunite himself with
his grandpa gohan's dragon ball
eventually he amended that desire in
lieu of the circumstances that befell
upa and his now late father pushing
forth with gusto towards fortune teller
baba's dwelling in search of an answer
for the final dragon ball's location
this portion of the story reminds us
that while the ark was named after the
red ribbon army due to its pervasive
pushback throughout the material
this story is still ongoing and at its
core
it's yet to be resolved so let's get to
the core essentially the long and short
of this particular portion of the story
concerns the retrieval of the last
dragon ball where is it the gang doesn't
know it's unable to be located using the
dragon radar for some reason and so they
go to fortune teller baba's dwelling in
the hopes that she can locate the ball
using her powers this is our first time
meeting this character her appearance is
fun and quirky and i just love the
design at first this seems like a great
solution to their problems however when
the gang arrive to find out that they
have to fight and defeat five champions
chosen by baba to get this privilege the
story once again turns into a tournament
of sorts fans of dragon ball super will
recognize this knockout style tournament
format as it was used during the
universe 6 tournament against the likes
of frost and hit unlike that tournament
and those fights from super however
these are distinctly early dragon ball
in both tone and execution for the most
part i'll show you what i mean first up
krillin vs count dracula krillin opts to
hop in to kick things off with this
challenge in the name of the hero team
first against none other than count
dracula almost all of baba's champions
follow this monster movie type theme and
the fight with krillin has some terrific
gag humor that actually got some laughs
out of me but through and through
there's not much to this fight beyond
some quick laughs and the establishment
of the tournament rules krillin loses
which means dracula stays on and up next
poor and up this fight is even shorter
though i will say its execution is cute
while also making some nice use of some
lesser utilized characters poor finally
gets to do something so that's cool and
oopa the person that's dictating the
story's conclusion also finds himself
contributing to the ending so that's
nice and i thought their involvement was
clever also with poor making full use of
his shape-shifting abilities dracula's
eliminated and to make room for yamcha
poar and upa step down next up yamcha
versus the invisible men this fight is a
really weird one and boy is it a time so
yamcha someone that's already struggling
with relevancy in the story finds
himself struggling against baba's
invisible man the only significant
instance from this fight is the
notorious bulma's boob panel
it's a gag that drags bulma and roshi
into the scene and through the group's
combined efforts krillin's idea lands a
large amount of roshi's blood over the
invisible man resulting in yamcha then
seeing him and taking the victory it's
one of the most bizarre scenes and now
we're switching the battle stage yamcha
proceeds to the next round his next
opponent the mummy yamcha vs the mummy
baba's third champion is perhaps the
first major challenge to this group and
therefore this is effectively where the
tournament actually starts everything
leading up to this was preamble or
comedic relief and while comedy remains
prevalent from here on what with the
battle stage literally being two giant
stone demons sitting on toilets while
tonguing each other the rules to this
one are simple you fall off the platform
you die from falling into the acid
beneath and if you quit you lose it's
that's it apparently and in this fight
with the mummy yamcha is quickly
overwhelmed making room for our main man
g that dons the orange gee
goku goku versus the mummy there's some
really nice panel work here and terrific
use of the mummy's powers to prevent him
from falling off the stage but in the
end this fight only serves to show one
thing how incredible goku is and how
blown away those in his friend group are
at his overwhelming strength in the end
goku was too much he advances baba's
next champion is
the devil while brief much like the
prior confrontation with the mummy
goku's fight with the devil is
interesting for two specific reasons i
think firstly this devil individual as
roshi points out to us is normally
baba's fifth champion which means
there's someone special waiting in the
wings to come out as her fifth secret
champion once goku disposes of the devil
man it's a nice teaser for later and at
that point in the story i was still none
the wiser as to who that surprise
fighter might be another aspect that i
thought was quite cool also kind of
funny was that of the devil man's secret
weapon this beam that he employs
enlarges the impurities or evil in one
soul until they explode or die but
what's cool about this is is that
it does nothing to goku he has no evil
in him and thus the beam did absolutely
nothing what i found funny however about
this section was that of baba's reaction
she seems to show tremendous concern for
goku's life and thought the devil was
going too far and her feeling that way
would be fine if not for the fact that
the ring is designed to have people fall
off to their death if you don't want the
fighters to die then don't make the
floor acid bubba but yeah as i alluded
towards the beginning of this video this
arc surrounding fortune teller baba and
her champions is very much the emotional
climax to this arc as well as the
culmination of the through line to this
entire story across its narrative goku
has traveled far and wide in search of
what began as loose reasons born out of
sentimentality in retrieving his
grandpa's treasured dragon ball and has
now evolved into a virtuous quest to
revive a friend's father and having now
fought and dismantled baba's devil her
former number one champion we sit and
wait for a surprise fifth champion to
make themselves known to both us the
readers
and goku
oh
this is one of my favorite encounters in
all of the dragon ball story including z
if there's one thing i would have liked
the series to lean more into later in
its stories it would have been a more
relationship focused story from the very
beginning of the dragon ball series
we've been made aware of the life goku
once had and through this long journey
we've grown to appreciate and understand
the little monkey child and the bizarre
habits he possessed he had no one but
over time grew strong and made loads of
wonderful new friends and one could
argue because of the lessons his grandpa
gohan instilled in him and having
started off this arc in search of an
item that represents his grandpa in the
end despite having to give up that for
someone else he still got what he wanted
in this scene goku versus his deceased
grandpa gohan is perfect from the subtle
hints leading up to the reveal utilizing
goku's sense of smell to gohan reminding
goku to bow all the way to the clever
use of his knowledge concerning goku's
weak points and while the fight is
something in and of itself to marvel
after i think what i love most about
this comes in the way of that subtle
breadcrumb hint trail that leads to the
outburst of emotion from goku at its
climax he's most definitely not the
sentimental sword nor is he the kind to
lament over or think nostalgically about
the past
but in this moment it's really brought
to the forefront of the story that he's
a little kid and he missed his grandpa
during a large portion of his life all
he had in the world
was him it's beautiful and i don't think
i was the only one who thought so either
i mean with dragon ball super paying
homage to this very moment in goku while
he was winning for frieza's arrival
during the tournament of power lead up
he relives the fight in his mind with
his late grandpa by going through the
techniques and poses used during the
encounter it's a moment that meant a lot
to him and when gohan took that mask off
the joy in goku as he's burst out crying
and smiling with a big hug is enough to
warm the coldest of hearts out there he
set out to find an important connection
to his friend pog through the four-star
ball he gave up on that goal for the
benefit of another and following that
path the young boy was reunited with his
grandpa one last time it's a beautiful
story following the events here and
thanks to the help of fortune teller
baba goku manages to locate the final
dragon ball brings up his father back to
the land of the living giving him the
same experience he had when reuniting
with his grandpa moments prior and
before the dragon balls fly off i
thought it was a great idea to have him
catch the four star ball and with that
comes an end to both this chapter and an
era of dragon ball for the next time we
see these characters it will be three
years into the future for the 22nd
tenkaichi budokai
[Music]
[Music]
one of the goals i set myself at the
beginning of this year was to be more
cautious with my spending i'm often
buying new equipment new material to
cover and paying my employees to keep
this channel running smoothly
honestly keeping track of everything is
really difficult so that's why i want to
share with you my solution to this
current
current is bringing banking to the
modern age and makes it super easy to
track your spending with their super
useful app when you sign up you get this
super swanky visa debit card and then
you can track your spending within the
app and even set up custom limits or
saving goals dealing with your personal
finances can be a real pain so having
these features built in is a real
blessing for me you've probably heard of
current before from a host of other
influencers but to me that shows that
they're really engaged with the current
platform and they are interested in
keeping this service current
if you are interested at all in trying
out this new system for yourself click
the link down in the description and
grab your card today and bring your
banking into the future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
normally while i'm reading a story i'll
take a step back part ways through and
try to place myself into the shoes of
the author i'll ask myself how i might
have progressed this story what's the
next logical continuation and the answer
while i was first reading this was i
have no idea we had just received the
payoff of what i consider to be the
story's longest running narrative
through line so far in goku reuniting
and getting closure for his grandpa
gohan this had been a question mark
dangling over the series and one akira
toriyama slowly drip-fed information
surrounding throughout the story until
it eventually came to a head during the
fortune teller baba material however now
looking back on this series in this
retrospective review i can identify what
i thought was a terrific choice in story
progression from the beginning of the
story through to the fortune teller baba
saga goku dealt with the consequences of
and received closure for a significant
event in his life through his grandpa it
was a story very much centered around
growth and finding friends through the
things he loved most like fighting these
were stories dealing with goku's past
and childhood development but this next
one this next arc marks the beginning of
a new chapter in goku's life the 22nd
tenkaichi budokai isn't about the past
it's about the future and the generation
that are primed to inherit it
immediately what sets this arc apart
from the prior is expectation we've been
shown how this format works and we're
familiar with all the hero characters
that are participating in how they fight
and that might sound great and all but
it's actually terrible because there's
no surprise these were the hurdles
initially in front of akira toriyama
when sizing up an approach to this
tournament arc i've spoken in the past
about what i love tournament arcs for
the action for me is very much secondary
to the opportunities it provides the
characters and the journey they go on
within this framework and because roshi
disguised as jackie chun led the charge
for the narrative last time in him
effectively being the point of view
character struggling against the odds
it's only fitting that he remains a
driving force this tournament arc 2 with
it effectively being his swan song but
that still leaves a number of other
characters lacking any sort of surprise
factor we've just seen yamcha and
krillin get benched easily in the first
part of this video and so we need a way
to care about them again well during the
closing moments of the last arc they all
come up with a plan of action concerning
the next world tournament right around
the corner krillin and yamcha opt to
train with roshi while roshi
specifically instructs goku to train on
his own around the world in the interim
while simple this effectively achieves
two things simultaneously number one it
gives krillin and yamcha a chance to
improve their standing next to goku and
the upcoming tournament and number two
having been effectively attached to
goku's hip the last while we've become
intimately aware of how strong he is as
readers so removing him from the
equation and skipping forward in time
after the mysterious training goku's
undergone is another great way to create
anticipation and secrecy surrounding
goku's true strength level these two
modifications on the status quo
following the last arc are important to
take stock of and recognize certainly
but perhaps the most significant and
memorable addition to this arc is
through the introduction of one or two
characters
[Music]
yamcha krillin jackie chun the newly
invigorated son goku and a nasty
relationship between two rival martial
arts schools in the crane and turtle
groups we've got all these question
marks right before the beginning of the
qualifying rounds this is gonna be a
great tournament the qualifying rounds
dashing back onto the scene having just
apparently ran from the other side of
the planet goku makes his presence known
with little effort qualifying for the
top 8 securing a spot in the
quarter-finals the purpose behind his
dominance once again continues the trend
established in the prior world
tournament that showed goku not as the
one to overcome adversity but to instead
empower him and to create a force for
roshi to overcome at this point in the
story this is still very much where our
heads are narratively can roshi do what
he managed to in the last tournament
again can he instill the necessary
philosophy and teachings in his pupil
goku in this arc it's also made obvious
that certain characters have grown
physically sporting different character
designs like new haircuts and new
outfits with yamcha and bulma making
that the most obvious change however
there are more subtle changes that i
really appreciated too for instance take
this image of goku after putting his
gion in this arc nothing to write home
about right he looks about the same as
he did before you might think well he's
actually a decent bit taller the pose he
takes here in this panel is drawn
specifically to evoke memories of an
earlier panel during the 21st tenkaichi
budokai wherein goku assuming the exact
same pose around the same time in the
tournament demonstrates his appreciation
for the clothing compare both of these
panels and you'll see for yourself the
difference in goku's new older character
design i think what this tournament
offers that the others didn't is a wider
variety of significant things to concern
ourselves with as readers we want to
know what yamcha and krillin are capable
of we want to see goku's new power and
we want to see how jackie chan will
contend with the up and coming
generation but really the wrench that's
thrown into this cacophony of conflict
has to be tenshinhan chautsu and the
crane school chiantsu is creepy the
crane hermit is cruel and tenshinhan is
the embodiment of their collective
teachings and how this individual
imposes his will on all the questions we
have concerning the turtle school is
what brings about the best in the story
with him immediately setting his sights
on yamcha and chiaotsu krillin and
because of this we immediately have
something to sink our teeth into
narratively for the quarter-finals
yamcha vs 10 shinhan this fight having
been made because ten shinhan told
chiltsu to force the numbers fighters
would choose using his psychic abilities
is another example of tin shinhan
forcing his will on the tournament's
activities and while tenchinhun does win
this fight he gets the first indication
that this group of turtle students
aren't your ordinary adversaries at
least not the sword he thought he would
encounter here with yamcha using
effectively his entire arsenal as well
as a surprise to both tin shinhan and to
us when he produces an exceptional
kamehameha the choreography and use of
space in this fight is something else
with the companion fight in the anime
sporting some outstanding animation and
artwork it's clear to see how far
everyone in this tournament has come
since the last one with the level of
fighting prowess on display throughout
however in the end tenshinhan comes out
victorious satisfied with the result
having thought yamcha was the school's
best competitor given his age he sets
his sights on what he perceives to be
the only other challenger that's worthy
of his time the winner of the 21st
tenkaichi budokai jackie chun as he
squares off against his quarterfinals
adversary man wolf man wolf versus
jackie chung of all the early matches
that have focused on comedy throughout
this story i think manuel versus jackie
chan is one of the greats it's by no
means visually interesting or compatibly
close instead it's a short funny
encounter that establishes a premise
plays with it and eventually pays it off
never to be seen again it exists to
communicate a short joke and it's great
at being that i think essentially this
dude manwolf is a reverse werewolf in
that it takes a full moon for him to
turn into a human again and thus he's
furious with jackie chun for blowing up
the moon in the prior tournament
allowing him to never become a human
again it seems it's a ridiculous premise
but one that breeds a lot of fun i
highly recommend checking it out if you
haven't seen it chiaotsu vs krillin this
fight right here is where tinchinhon
starts to reevaluate his assessment of
these fighters and begins acknowledging
their abilities in their own right more
so with goku but this fight has some
stuff too worth discussing i think this
might be the only fight chaos
participates in where he looks in any
way threatening toriyama really leans
into his creep factor particularly in
how he communicates his sudden and quick
movements that coupled with some
unconventional and never before seen
attacks krillin finds himself on the
back foot time and time again however
thanks to his ability to think on his
feet and chouch's inability to do so
krillin confuses the little psychic long
enough to score the vic it's not a super
impressive fight by any means but
there's some funny jokes and it really
leans into krillin being more of a
strategist than an actual fighter
panput vs son goku something i neglected
to mention during goku's qualifying
matchups was that he matched with a
former winner of the tournament and in
the blink of an eye eliminated him with
absolute ease this trend continues with
the character of panput a prodigy pegged
to be the next best thing in the martial
arts world and with all of the promise
and accolades attached to his name goku
once again without any trouble totally
dismantles him in front of everyone
securing his trip into the semi-finals
of this tournament alongside the likes
of jackie chun tenshinhan and krillin
what i liked about the ending of this
fight was that it mirrored tenshinhan's
qualifying display where all the turtle
students remark at the number of strikes
he lands leading to his opponent's loss
in that same way with goku's victory
tension and remarks in amazement at the
speed and number of strikes goku lands
to secure his victory in this moment 10
shinhan recognizes goku as something
special but he's still not impressed the
semi-finals
these semi-finals are a star-studded
affair fondly remembered in the annals
of dragon ball history or at least they
very well should be featuring fights
between goku and krillin and tin shinhan
and jackie chun they are both terrific
fights with a lot of narrative and
emotional weight behind them and for me
these semi-final fights are the anchor
of this entire arc here's why 10 shinhan
versus jackie chun a significant driving
force behind the actions 10 shinhan and
the crane school take is that of
dominance tenchinon has been taught to
crush and has been encouraged to
humiliate anyone that would dare think
they could be superior to him and i
personally think that specific aspect of
his character that character flaw is
precisely why this fight against roshi
is one of the best in the series and the
perfect send-off to the jackie chan
persona a running theme that's been
following roshi like a shadow as he
engages in training with his pupils and
the various tournaments has been that of
succession and responsibility since the
story began he's been the almost
reluctant holder of the title
responsible for the earth's well-being
it's a responsibility that's become his
through the strength he sought to
achieve in his youth and keeping all of
that in mind it re-contextualizes to a
certain extent his teachings with
krillin goku and yamcha as soon as goku
releases his first kamehameha
roshi acknowledged goku as special and
came out of his isolationist lifestyle
to once again engage with what he
believed to be a promising new
generation and in pulling that thread it
led him to this fight with ten shinhan
once again in a tournament to help
foster the next generation only this
time something feels different
throughout the battles he's witnessed
during the build-up to this tournament
as well as baba and before roshi has
consistently been blown away by what
others predominantly goku have been able
to do and right before he goes to face
off against tenshin on he takes the time
to have this interaction with goku and
krillin concerning panpout
[Applause]
and so going into this battle against
tin shinhan all he needed was a little
push and a push then shinhan most
certainly gave him this battle is
awesome roshi once again is forced to
get serious and throw out all sorts of
tricks to push tenshinhan until chen
shows him something he wasn't expected
the choreography in this battle is
stupendous and what's more is roshi
takes this as an opportunity to try and
convince ten shinhan that his talents
are better served elsewhere punctuated
with a choice from roshi as impactful
and surprising for tenchinon as it was
for goku and the guys in the back he
exits the ring leaving ten shinhan with
the knowledge that he did so without
using his full power brilliant fight
brilliant story
[Music]
[Music]
a brilliant piece of dialogue that
caught my attention was something roshi
said to ten shinhan during goku and
krillin's fight as well as ten's
response
this is something i think modern dragon
ball loses sight of personally with the
introduction of characters like vegeta
later on down the line the narrative
flirts with the notion that pride is not
only okay but it's a path that's worthy
of going down when in reality pride is
nothing but the source of shame and it
is precisely what this moment between
ten shinhan and roshi points out i
honestly missed this philosophical angle
the story would take and its positioning
within the opening of krillin and goku's
first ever match was something i thought
perfectly echoed that scene sentiments
as his two students proceed into battle
not with the sole ambition of winning or
being the strongest but to instead test
their abilities against someone they
respect taking all of this in it's
wonderful getting to see roshi exiting
these semi-finals following a loss not
with a sense of disappointment or shame
but instead with a feeling of deep
comfort knowing that the future is
bright with these impressive individuals
leading the charge and speaking of those
leading the charge goku's fight with
krillin is something to behold the
camaraderie demonstrated both off and on
the fighting stage is heartwarming but
the respect each competitor shows each
other is remarkable with krillin asking
goku not to hold back or he won't ever
forgive him and goku claiming that this
is the most fun fight he's ever had
impressive in both the manga and anime
making full use of their respective
mediums the philosophy surrounding this
fight as i mentioned is fantastic but
once again it is yet another fight that
has some stupendous toriyama
choreography exploiting every angle and
utilizing some unique uses for the
kamehameha from both competitors goku
using it as a booster to give his
punches more power and krillin using it
defensively to create an opening for him
to grab his tail once again leading into
the strategic workarounds in his persona
unluckily for krillin however in the
three years since they last saw each
other goku removed that weakness and
once that option was removed krillin was
simply outmatched by the young fighter
goku emerges victorious with a nice bit
of writing between the referee and goku
to cap everything off at the end the
referee says to goku the next batch is
the championship round would you like to
take a break and goku responds puzzled
and i don't care goku very much valued
that fight but it by no means pushed him
at all this next fight should be a fun
one the finals sun goku versus 10
shinhan
the beginning of this fight is filled
with strategy encounters initially
losing early on goku impressed with
tenshihan's power and toughness decides
to push harder and harder getting into
an apparent advantageous position early
on as tin shinhan in the air is primed
for kamehameha but goku chooses not to
use it it's subtle but i love this
indication that he's taken on board
different pieces of advice he's been
offered growing up as a young kid he was
criticized for not thinking things
through and charging in head-on but
right here you can see the strategy he's
employing he's aware that this opponent
is powerful and has the ability to fly
he might dodge it he thinks this fight
will be a long one and he needs that
energy towards the beginning of this
fight tension on particularly when it
comes to the vanishing technique goku
uses and has used against krillin in the
past he immediately recognizes the move
from the prior fight and counters it
immediately but as the fight wears on
goku implements similar applied learning
to the tao ken or solar flare if you've
seen the dub immediately snatching roshi
sunglasses allowing him to land a heavy
blow onto tenshinhan i love choreography
like this it's massively fun and i love
the pervasive use of callbacks to
earlier points in the arc and further
setting this fight apart every fight
from the qualifiers up until now have
been relatively short lasting no longer
than a chapter or two and so narratively
because this is given ample time to
breathe it feels all the more
significant and huge as a final it feels
like a massive occasion the fight isn't
over in an instant it lasts long enough
to tell a story and for us as an
audience to feel the rhythm of that
story tien's impressed tien gains the
upper hand goku's impressed goku gains
the upper hand but the real overarching
story concerning this encounter and
really this entire tournament has
concerned itself with the struggle for
tin shinhan's soul during roshi's fight
with tin shinhan a large part of it
focused on roshi trying to instill some
sort of lesson in the young fighter
recognizing that he has so much
potential as a martial artist despite
his horrible master and during this
fight with goku his allegiances are
tested in ways he never anticipated
[Music]
this is an important moment not simply
because it finally creates a moment for
attention hunt to distance himself from
the crane school but instead because it
sets in motion a trend whereby the
villains secure their own downfall
personally i love this narrative choice
and it is by far and away my favorite
narrative tool to dispose of villains
not just in dragon ball but the wider
world i first noticed this technique
used in the film tarzan as a child when
clayton the story's villain through his
blind hate-filled pursuit of tarzan
inadvertently hangs himself despite
tarzan's greatest efforts to prevent him
from doing so it's a simple but
massively effective tool that highlights
the villain's flaws and amplifies the
hero's virtues and in dragon ball later
this technique will be used to bring
about the downfall of the series two
most iconic villains and right here in
classic dragon ball we see the impetus
for this narrative technique master
crane demands that tenshinhan kill goku
not understanding his pupil or the honor
he wants to conduct this match with and
despite his screams for murder death and
revenge he gets a kamehameha courtesy of
master roshi sending him flying i love
this scene following this tenshinhan
brings to light techniques goku could
never have imagined sprouting two
additional arms creating instances where
goku can't defend himself but primed us
as an audience for swerves like goku
using his tail as a fifth appendage to
even the odds this is such a fun and
creative fight and honestly it pains me
that we don't see more creative
implementation of maneuverings in modern
dragon ball fights they offer so much
entertainment and to think that these
are concepts or relics of a bygone era
is honestly quite sad everyone nowadays
wants their latest transformations or
flashy beams but back here we had
legitimate strategy using moves never
before seen in the story it makes the
world feel so incredibly colorful that
is until the climax to this fight
for when tenshinhan bellows the name of
this technique the color is zapped from
the faces of chiaotsu krillin and roshi
respectively
terrified both for goku and tenshinhan
there are so many ups and downs to this
fight at this point it's clearly the
most intense in the series made evident
by the number of story beats and the
fact that the stage has been
disintegrated but narrowly having
escaped by jumping high into the air
goku remains tenshinhan is drained and
goku readies one last kamehameha
the one he saved for such an occasion
earlier in the conflict but instead
knowing that tin shinon has an answer
for that technique as made evident in
his prior encounters goku once again
finds a creative use for the blast
knowing that he can't fly fast enough to
evade a blow propelled by the force of a
kamehameha goku launches himself like a
rocket towards the weary fighter they
both hurtled towards the ground and the
first to touch down loses goku manages
to expel just enough energy to put
himself above tension and when
[Music]
first reading this i was stunned given
the subject matter and philosophy of the
prior world tournament it stood to
reason that he would likely lose the
21st tenkaichi budokai i mean come on it
was his first and that was the lesson of
the outing at the end of the day but to
lose it again for a second time at the
finish line i was stunned every fight
leading up to this encounter had goku
like a powerhouse steamrolling through
the competition and to have him lose
here albeit in a questionable manner was
stunning for me to read first time
through the fight was incredible it had
some interesting narrative choices and
was the single best visual fight
toriyama had produced to date in my
estimation but somewhat remarkably this
arc wouldn't be remembered for this
fight but instead remembered for its
aftermath
[Music]
[Music]
the unthinkable has happened a terrific
tournament has ended in tragedy next
week i will cover what many consider to
be the very best original dragon ball
has to offer when i dive into the king
piccolo arc and beyond i'll see you
there
[Music]
foreign